na playoffs from masters reykjavik have
finished up and we have our two
representatives the guard and optic
booked and busy to represent us despite
any playoffs finishing we have some
interesting developments to discuss so
buckle up baby
all right everyone before we get into
the video i gotta remind you as always
the like button the subscribe button to
ring the notification bell if you don't
i can't tell you about the newest hat i
just ordered to cover up my weird
hairline that dance gives you so
get ready you're gonna like my new hat
danny you're gonna like it folks the na
state of the union is good
that is a political joke i have a degree
in political science just please let me
use it once anyways dumb jokes aside na
is looking pretty damn good and i know
i'm not the only one who feels this way
na looked clean and i think most
importantly smart not only do we have
the firepower after this weekend it is
clear we have the brain power but for
those of you who are unable to tune in i
can give you the spark notes of what
happened the past two weekends so you
can impress everyone in your discord vc
because god knows your irls don't know
or don't care
maybe that's just me
anyways after weeks of games it finally
happened the guard won n a stage one
after a grueling best of five and a
teeny tiny lower bracket run in playoffs
in order to make it the guard had to
defeat sentinels luminosity cloud9 and
optic maybe even potentially contest
marvin on the site's good yay gonna
reveal himself still holding on to his
teammates the train's coming back and
forth but it's optic with the numbers
yay two good from deep
el diablo tries to rendezvous back
what is this a divine comedy for dante's
inferno by saya player 1v1 with crap
zaya player for the double and if you're
like liz this sounds familiar it's
because i called it [ __ ] y'all
doubted me i saw y'all in the comments
he was laughing now
anyways the best part is the guard
actually lost to optic in the upper
final and then came back and beat them
in the grand final optic didn't lose
until that grand final
they have looked great and consistent
for over a year now they're precise and
yay i mean is anyone as good as yay
actually asked the guards don't appear
what he thought happened when the guard
lost to optic on bind and his answer was
we couldn't
shut down yay's op on bind pretty much
our comp is like pretty difficult to
deal with that deal with operas because
we don't have a soba and we only have
like a like a skydog to deal with it
and he was just all over the map and
we couldn't handle it and when i asked
yay just about how he did that this was
his response for me i think i had like a
pretty good understanding of like what
they were trying to do like across the
map
um and i think i was having like a
pretty good game when we went to bind
bind there's always been like a really
like at least lately it's been
one of our strongest maps every time
we've played vine i think we've
with the exception of like one team uh
they got to start a group stage we've
lost but like every other time like we
we've won you know pretty convincingly
combined so we felt we felt really
confident going into it so the guard and
optic are our representatives of an a
but i would be remiss if i did not talk
about some of the other teams who
competed first i want to talk about
knights and before you go liz your hot
take about night speeding exit was wrong
i've been made aware of this mistake i
pay the price by being called out on
twitter by their head coach but in my
defense of that hot take knights have
shown tremendous improvement in the past
i've beaten ryze energy and in these
playoffs and managed to take a map off
of cloud9 i spoke to frosty the team's
igl and asked him if the newer attention
on the team was scary that was kind of
one of our advantages coming into like
other tournaments and vct people didn't
expect us and then we just come out
swinging peeking them out trading them
out aiming them and like every aspect of
the game it'll definitely be harder with
more people watching your vods paying
attention to us but it's not going to
stop us we also need to talk about
accept because exit looked good they
were just shy of qualifying for iceland
but they looked strong i was able to
talk to a few of the exit players i
wanted to highlight a few things one
second talked about except's continued
improvement adding no pressure to them
even if other teams are becoming more
aware of them i don't think it really
adds much pressure because like i think
just for the majority of like
top 12 ish teams in north america like
you usually know their kind of play
style or you can see their vods and know
what they're going to do so i feel like
people kind of seeing us as a formidable
team is more added pressure to them
because they'll be like oh my god we're
going up against exit than it is to us
being like oh man they know so much
about us because i feel like if we're
playing how we're normally playing and
we're communicating well and you know
we're hitting our shots it's really
difficult to beat us even if they know
what we're gonna do two bcj talked about
the importance of setting up your
teammates for success when i first ran
on this team i used to be
the guy that people made plays for you
know like oh let's get brennan in a spot
this round this round whatever and
having you know bringing on matt
bringing on zeke and for example two
players that we kind of like to do those
things around build those plays around
them in a way so we've had to set them
up i've had to learn you know okay what
can i do to make them
play better
feel better whatever it may be
communication wise gameplay-wise
whatever version one also played
incredibly well something that really
stood out to me of the team was their
desire to improve and always do better i
talked to penny after a win and he
wasn't satisfied with their performance
we didn't really play our best but
that's kind of what we should have
played in the first game against lg if
you look at the last series compared to
when we played sentinels versus this one
we obviously made more mistakes this one
maybe that's because they had more like
stuff on us i guess now because we
played them but
yeah we didn't play as good as we played
against them last time later when i
spoke to effie's he said that their loss
to lg on fracture made them go back to
the drawing board we actually like we
knew against that against lg we lost to
ourselves on the ct side of fracture so
a lot of prep work we did before this
game was actually focused on city side
fracture also we have to talk about the
neon picks we saw from both knights and
optic i talked to optics yay about that
pick who gave me a little bit of insight
we saw gambit and we saw like a few
other teams like trying out that neon
and we kind of saw like the ideas they
were going for
and
victor already has experience on neon
because obviously you know with like the
whole caveman thing and our split like
last time was a little bit rough so it
was kind of like a it was kind of like a
last second change of like hey let's
give this a try because like we've had
success with neon in the past this
team's running beyond we see like a lot
of opportunity why not give it a try
also huge shout out to lg for proving
everyone wrong and ruining all of our
brackets
i'm very excited to see what they'll do
in the future i talk to so many players
over these two weekends and i wish i
could include all of our conversations
but let me just say this
the reason why i say the state of n a is
good is because of these conversations
i've had the hunger these players have
the desire to be better and win i came
into these playoffs a huge skeptic of
the region i'm supposed to cheer for
and i have left now convinced n.a will
win iceland furthermore i am so glad
that teams that deserve our attention
are finally being given our due
diligence teams like lg knights our
attention aren't just on one team of the
region but all the other teams that
exist in n a and i think that is swell
what we have seen with this stage is
that time dedication and belief in a
team can go a long way
not just switching things up the minute
things don't work out yes there is some
text to that but i'll let you all figure
that out
masters one reiki vic starts april 10th
really not that far away and i am pretty
damn excited to see the best of the best
battle it out on the international stage
um when i was interviewing yay i asked i
always just like to ask players like
moving forward like what are mistakes
that you don't want to make like you
know just like you want to work on post
plans or something like that and yay
without missing a beat told me that his
first game he did arm day and he told me
because of like him doing like a really
intense arm day he kept whipping his
shots and um i asked him the second time
i was like oh was it like what date was
it arm day today he's like no it's
actually cardio today
zoom zoom zoom who's editing this
colton
golden
oh